yeah morning members hopefully everyone
can hear clearly at the back there
welcome to the planning committee today
on the 22nd of March 2023
I'm your chair councilor lincolnman
Bradbury
just a few quick announcements obviously
if the fire alarm should ring can I ask
you to please leave the room by the door
behind me and assemble in the car park
in the sunshine at the moment actually
please if you've got a mobile phone with
you please can you switch it off so it
doesn't disturb the meeting
I don't believe we have any public
speakers at this meeting today
but can I just also remind members if
you're not in the meeting to hear the
entire debate then you are not able to
vote on the application
um could I also ask you if you do wish
to speak
to wave your hand and gentlemen will
come along with a microphone so you can
be heard heard clearly on the feedback
okay
so let's start with the agenda items
please
apologies for abstinence please
thank you chair apologies from
councilor's Dewhurst Hayes Jeffrey
Kurzweil Peart and Russell
thank you for that
um the next item to consider is the
minutes from the last meeting on 15th of
February 2023 our members content for me
to sign them as a true record can have
someone to
propose and second that please
thank you and a show of hands that
you're happy to thank you that's for any
against
and any abstentions
thank you
that's fine thank you
so
um
we resolved that let's go on to the
first item before us which is 19
01 274
Connie bear wood Kurzweil with and
if
our beg your pardon
because it's there in front of me I'm
very sorry
no I haven't gosh okay thank you
um that's just totally thrown me so I do
apologize members I was looking at the
minutes and going through that so can I
ask members for any Declarations of
Interest please
underneath the two items before us
nope
we don't have any public participation
which I've already mentioned I've
already made enough announcements I
think for one meeting so that's
absolutely fine so we will now go on to
the first item to consider which is
22.0223 Dayton Folly
um we have a planning officer Nikki
Warner with us today who's going to take
us through the item thank you Nikki
hello so daint and Folly is a previously
converted bond in Dayton
it's a staff member which is why this
has come to committee and the changes
from the public domain are fairly
minimal there's some changes to the
fenestration at
on the front elevation so the pains that
you can see there are going to be
replaced with some opening Velux the
central panes there is an extension to
the rear
uh which is single story and the first
there's a first floor
extension which is a small
uh bathroom
the revisions are fairly minimal very
much in keeping with the host property
and the vernacular of the area
and
our recommendation is
to approve it
there's also the changing of a flat roof
garage to a pitch slated roof
which can be seen in the front garden
okay okay Nikki that's it yeah thank you
obviously as Nikki has mentioned this is
before us because it is a member of
staff's property so can I open up to
members if there's any comments or
um
any debate on this item please
cancel Clarence yeah I'm just
the microphones coming your way okay
we're not with the officers like to tell
me I see here in the approval that
provision should be made for B bricks
and with Hedgehog holes whatever I've
never seen a b brick or and Hedgehog
holes in it what the heck is it I mean
I don't have any examples with me but
they are things that we can use as
um to help us
through the roof no it's a very easily
obtainable minimal cost addition that
will help enhance biodiversity I'm sure
the bees will love it and good luck for
the month you know we're only expect
in the property so it's it's
um I see a bug hotel with lots of holes
I'm sure what what B bricks are whether
there's special requirements for bees
and the Hedgehog hole is just about
having a gap in the fence so if you are
putting up any new fencing you make sure
there's a hedgehog highway so they can
move between Gardens
very commendable thank you
thank you councilor Clarence that we've
all been educated by your question so
thank you thank you for that any other
comments or points on that is anyone
happy to
um to propose this item
thank you
thank you councilor Parker okay
okay so if there's no further comments
we will go to the vote please thank you
to approve our set out
full
I think so thank you we don't need to go
any further with that thank you ladies
and gentlemen
that's approved as set out
we will now go on to the next item
if I could please call the officer for
this one
Steve Hobbs enforcement officer so
they're just going to do a quick
changeover
and over to you Steve thank you
thank you chair
and
firstly I just want to just um confirm
why the matter has been brought before
the planning committee it's just that
the reason is that it could it's really
wrapped we got in residential use of the
Caravans and any action we take could
make the occupants homeless which is
let's say that's the reason it's been
brought to the committee there's not any
other requests in any other way
um the sites I've run to it
the site is um this means the subject to
a number of um prior approvals over the
years
um for a number of the buildings
um I'll just go through a couple of
um the most recent one is the permission
for converting This Barn
on this one into residential
accommodation
um so it was granted by the prior
approval
um which is basically allowing it as a
permitted development but as part of
that process they have to agree the
habitat Regulators which um has been the
sort of sticking points on this and
that's until all that's agree there's no
lawful right to actually reside on the
land
um and what's happened in this instance
the Caravans being brought on prior to
that all being agreed and Still Remains
outstanding and so does the residential
use so in order to
progress or take action because I like
the time it's been there
um it's come to committee and
that's it I feel the information here's
the photographs of what's there at the
moment
there's a couple of photos a couple of
Caravans on site one's occupied by the
one of the owners and the others by this
being used by their son
there's a sort of domestic stuff around
the size we say it's been there for
about 12 months
um basically just to summarize it says
the owner is being fully aware of a need
to satisfy the habitat regulations since
the planning inspector
um
attach the conditions to an original
approval
um since then the owners had two
refusals of Regulation 77 on the habitat
race
and um
despite this the owners continue to live
on the site since April 22 in full
knowledge of the requirements
um that require the works we carried out
I understand that you've all been
contacted by the owner
um separately and um I said that they've
appreciate that as in the um update
um if there's any questions anybody has
on that
all done okay
um yeah we've had that have a change of
um
the actual recommendation hopefully
members you've noted that on the uh um
no sorry okay I'll just I'll just could
you read that yeah basically what's that
um I've received confirmation from the
one of the owners that um they are
occupying it that they do have a house
that they're working on at the moment
and it's going to take between sort of
six to eight weeks to get that completed
the original recommendation was that if
the use didn't cease by the end of this
month and we would look at taking action
but we've moved that back to the end of
April and that we should tie in with the
time period
okay thank you for that
um so the the actual recommendation now
is saying that it's yeah until the end
of April 2023. so I just wanted to
clarify that I was I was hopeful
everyone had seen that from that point
of view
um I've received a statement from the
Ward member who is I'm not going to go
through it all but he's in full support
of of this action
um are there any comments or any
questions from Members I'll throw it out
to the floor please
thank you chair the information that's
new that wasn't in the report and wasn't
in um the information we received from
the applicant is the fact that they've
had two refusals of the reg 77 already
that's new information to me because
in my mind I was thinking the applicant
is just
um or the person that has an action
taken against them
um was just waiting for the council to
get back on this habitat's rake
situation and that really it was just
our delay that was um the problem and
therefore if you know if we Jolly well
got on with it then then they would be
entitled to be in their Caravan so the
new information to me is the fact that
they've already had two refusals of that
so can we have a bit more detail on that
then is is the action in their hands now
are they being expected to do something
that we're waiting for
um currently at the moment we've still
got a
um pending condition to be discharged on
the habitat rakes and the detail the
most up-to-date details were submitted
in January 23 and so they're being
looked at by our biodiversity officer at
the moment
um but it's also then it should
depending on the outcome of that as well
if that's approved then yes they do have
a consent in place to do the works but
then there's still need to then look at
discharging the habitat rakes for the
sighting of the mobile home and any
impact that may have on it
and just to clarify the section 77
process is under the conservation of
habitats and species regulations so it's
not under
um the general permitted development
order it's a it's a separate um piece of
legislation all permitted development
rights are subject to there's a article
3 at the front of the general permitted
development order says you only have
permitted development rights if you
comply with the habitat regulations so
you can't do any plan or project that
would be permitted under the general
permitted development order if you
cannot also comply with the habitat
regulations and the habitat regulations
say that you should not proceed with any
project that would that has the
potential to have
um an effect on the Integrity of a
European site
the European site in question here is
the south ham Sac so this is bats bat
flyways in and around the chudley area
we are to the north east of chudley here
and in a quarry with a significant
number of trees around it the greater
horseshoe bats are significantly light
averse
so we need to know and understand what
the impact of the light spill from the
proposed barn conversions would be on
bats on their flyways they're foraging
their their habits at the site and we
can ask for whatever information we need
to go through that process and we have
um been talking to the applicants here
for uh you know a number of years about
the use of the site by bats and light
spill light statements making sure that
we've got accurate and appropriate
information when we have the right
information we then have to consult
Natural England so there's a three-week
natural income consultation period and
only so there's the involvement of
Natural England in this as well so if
the application was submitted to us in
January and we're now in morning late
March
actually given the process that we've
got to go through I don't think there's
been undue delay here and it the it is
incumbent on the applicant to make sure
that we've got enough information and
that they are being sufficiently clear
about what it is that they are doing and
the impact that will have on the bats
for us to say that it's okay
so we we have already because there is
the planning history at this site and we
are aware that Natural England are
concerned about the impact development
on this site because we've had to go
through the process previously with them
we've we've tried to to reach agreement
on on issues here previously so it is
incumbent on us to make sure that we are
um issuing a robust decision that we do
have the information that we need so if
the application came in in January and
it's only not yet the end of March I
don't think that we are being
um
unduly slow in dealing with that one
okay thank you for that clarification
did you want to come back on that Jackie
or you
and I've got cancer Clarence who wants
to come in as well are you also saying
then that even the Caravans they they
need to have that same so you're saying
the same so in the sense they shouldn't
be there for that that reason also
um
okay no I I think that's a bit clearer
and and you and if they do have a house
to go to in eight weeks time then that
does alter it somewhat okay thank you
foreign
what's been said about the alteration of
the recommendation what's your actual
plan to go and
this compliance is asked for by the end
of April so is it your plan to visit the
site in the first week in May and see
what's happened and then if things
haven't been if you're not happy with
everything are you going to bring it
back to us at a future planning meeting
then is that is that the plan of the way
ahead it wasn't the idea is today is to
get the authorization that if it hasn't
been complied with by that time period
then we a server notice them
hopefully you'll have a new the home
will be completed
does it have a b brick
no sorry I don't need you to want
even if they haven't moved off
and noticing
simple so that that there is an end date
and that this use this unauthorized use
will be brought to an end you know even
if that then means that there are
appeals and other steps that we need to
go through it's really important that we
get the notice in place so that the the
length of time doesn't drag on any
further that that we don't have a notice
in place or an unauthorized residential
use in the countryside
thank you
okay any other questions or statements
on this at all
the microphones just
microphones on its way
there you go I'd like to move but that
was the course of action we take I'll
set out today as set out yes thank you
sorry
yeah the the revive just to clarify the
revised recommendation yeah
okay thank you is anyone happy to second
that
councilor Clarence thank you
so we have a proposal and a second so I
will ask for a vote please those for the
proposal are set out
okay that's eight and those against
any abstentions
three thank you
so that is carried thank you
um
just some of the business
um members to before we come to the end
of this meeting
can I draw your attention to the appeal
decisions we just need to to note that
and he caught just offering any comments
um if necessary
and you'll want to speak to the appeals
decision just to we're just here to note
them so
please yep
yeah just for a matter of Interest the
final one Kings occur as well what do
you mean by turned away
the appeal it might be because they were
out of time so there's a time limit on
um different decisions for when you can
get an appeal made or sometimes you have
to be a specific category of person so
sometimes you have to have an ownership
interest or something to be able to make
in the field so not accepted by the
planning inspector
okay thank you so members that I'm not
seeing anything to the contrary member's
happy for me to for us to note the
appeals as set out
we don't have any major planning
decisions to go through so with that on
that note I will thank you for your
attendance today and close the meeting
thank you members